-My next guest is a very
talented actor and comedian.
He stars in the movie
"The Right One,"
which is available now
on digital and on demand.
Here is Nick Thune!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -Better make room
for my man Nick Thune ♪
♪ Serves jokes with a tune ♪
♪ That's what you get
with Nick Thune ♪
♪ Better make room
for my man Nick Thune ♪
♪ Jokes with a tune ♪
♪ Nick Thune ♪
-Nick, thank you for coming
in the studio to see us.
It means a lot to us.
Welcome back.
-Well, thanks, Jimmy.
I feel great here.
-The last time you were on
the show, you were nice enough.
We were doing the show
from my home.
And you were nice enough
to come on the show then.
And you had a very funny video
about homeschooling your son.
How's everything
going with your son?
Is it still difficult?
-You know, I have not seen him.
He's been in juvie
for about six months.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Oh, my God. Oh, it's terrible.
I'm sorry. What happened?
-People don't realize
how easy it is
to frame your kid for a crime.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. I did not know.
-I just thought this is
a better school system for him.
[ Laughter ]
-Good for you.
-Yeah.
It's like going to a fun
summer camp all year.
Yeah. That's the thing
I like about you.
You're not selfish, you know?
-No, no, no, no. Never.
-I want to talk about --
I want to talk about
"The Right One," your movie.
I love seeing you act.
I've said this before
because I was watching "Venom,"
I want to say, the Marvel movie.
-Yeah.
-You're in the Marvel Universe.
I saw you in "Venom,"
and I go --
Dude, that was fantastic.
What did that feel like?
-Oh, my God, it was so good.
I had a role.
The name was like Kevin,
you know?
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Please sit down, everybody.
Please sit down.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone remembers Kevin.
-I played --
Well, I was playing Kevin,
and then as a joke,
because the scene was in a bar
and I was, like, joking with
Tom, my buddy Tom Hardy.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-And I said that'd be funny
if my name was Beardo at the Bar
instead of Kevin.
-Yeah.
-And the director heard that.
So somehow in the credits
it does say Beardo at the Bar
now instead of Kevin,
if you like, look me up on IMDB.
-I actually printed out
this IMDB.
You're going to have to
really zoom in here.
Look down where
it's highlighted here.
-Yeah. It's really
right next to Tom. Yeah.
-It's almost up next to Tom.
You keep calling him Tom, yeah.
Beardo at the Bar.
So they took Kevin
away from you?
-Yeah. And then I realized why.
Because Beardo at the Bar is
such a great Marvel character,
you know, and the idea of,
you know, we want to know more.
What's he doing at the bar?
How come a beard?
That kind of stuff.
-Yeah. Those questions.
-Yeah.
-Those questions spring up.
You go, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's all good.
-What's that guy's story?"
[ Laughter ]
-More about Beardo at the Bar.
-I feel like you could --
Don't you want him back
in the Marvel Universe, Beardo?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I would love to see it.
-Thank you.
-Nick, comedy clubs
are slowly opening up again.
Thank goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was tough on everybody,
and you're a great comedian.
Are you happy
to go back to clubs?
-Yeah. Yeah.
In fact, I was at The Cellar
all week here, going up
and got some new material.
If you don't -- Me and the staff
all got together
and got this for you.
-Oh.
The material?
-Yeah.
-Oh, wow. Thank you.
Oh, this is fantastic.
-Yeah.
So, this is a song I wrote.
It's a song about a lost dog,
and it's hard to tell
if I lost her or misplaced her
or what really happened.
The song is called "Here, Girl,"
and this is something I wrote,
you know, when I was really
creative over the...
♪♪
[ Whistling ]
Here, girl, come on!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
-Beautiful.
-I've also been doing
some noodling.
I don't know if you like noodles
or not.
-Of course.
-Well, I'd love to give you
a plate of them.
♪♪
You know, I was thinking
on my 35th birthday,
I was in the kitchen
at my house.
I was having a party.
A friend came in and we were
just chatting, and he said,
"Isn't it funny that the word
cupboard is spelled with a B
but everyone thinks
that it's with a P?"
[ Laughter ]
And I thought, "Yeah,
why would it be cup-board?
That's dumb.
Of course it's with a B."
So, anyway, three years go on.
38th birthday,
I'm in the same kitchen.
Same friend walks up to me
and he goes,
"Oh, hey, by the way,
it is spelled with a P."
[ Laughter ]
And that's three years
that I'll never get back.
-Yeah, no, absolutely not.
-You know?
Anyway, I know Memorial Day
is coming up and...
[ Laughter ]
You know, I support
the military,
and I just think it's so sad
that they only get one
4:20 a day.
[ Laughter ]
It's so early, you know,
and it's just --
it's 16:20 when you're high.
It's so confusing.
[ Laughter ]
And, yes, Jimmy,
that is a military-time joke.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-And if you don't mind,
I'd like to tell two more.
[ Laughter ]
-We'd love it.
-Or do I want to tell 14?
[ Laughter ]
I've got no idea.
You don't tell military time.
Military tells you time.
-Oh! That's what
I'm talking about.
[ Applause ]
Nick Thune, everybody.
That's noodling and some
deep thoughts right there.
I love you, buddy.
Thanks so much.
-Thanks for having me.
-Good to see you. Nick Thune!
"The Right One" is available
on digital and on demand.
Look for Beardo coming soon.